[Musique]
large n'est pas dangereux large est un
un phénomène naturel qui se développe
pendant les mois de printemps et d'été dans le
latitudes moyennes mais aussi aux pôles tout
ce qui assombrit la neige la provoque
la fusion car elle l'accélère
l'absorption du rayonnement
[Musique]
ici, nous n'essayons pas de
quantifier l'effet d'autres phénomènes
qui s'ajoutent au direct
d'impact humain qui ont du caractère
plus naturel mais ils peuvent avoir dans
une certaine manière d'établir des relations avec le
présence par exemple de l'homme à ces derniers
altitude via les remontées mécaniques e
randonnée
[Musique]
qui a un problème, ça nous manque
des algues qui nous aident malheureusement nous le sommes
causant des dommages irréversibles et nous sommes
Je suis déjà au bord du non-retour je pense
[Musique]